so we were talking offline that you're
not just getting into programming what
what's uh
the most beautiful program you've ever
written something that brought you joy
there's something
i really love completion it's the reason
that i'm
addicted to songwriting i like there
being nothing
and then having some blocks or tools
and building them into what you want it
to look like
and then i find it incredibly rewarding
to
stand back and and look at what you did
at the end
it could be anything for me it's it was
as simple to begin with that's just you
know
because it's our object-oriented like
making a cube move like that as simple
as that understanding that and knowing
that i built that and made it do that
is
really rewarding uh and i think it's the
thing that drew me into
to wanting to learn more
but as far as what is some grandio like
some big piece of code that i've done
like absolutely not it's more i'm still
a level where it's more like what is a
tutorial that i followed right and and
got you know and and then you know
yeah so i couldn't say i'm at a level
where i've done anything beautiful at
all in code but you're also interested
in potentially
like your heart is drawn to creating
games
creating anything um and completing it
yeah that's the good to feel good as
it's done
yeah i've i mean i've been working over
the last two years um
with actually a team out of kiev
uh on and and we can get into that it's
a whole another story but on a computer
game
and
really i've kept that kind of under
under wraps but
yeah we're kind of getting to a point
now where we have a prototype that we
can play and it's a lot of fun and and
uh thankfully all the team members are
in safe places now
things have obviously been on hold for a
little bit but
you know when that started is when i
really
decided okay i need to understand
base level coding in c sharp so i'm not
an idiot talking to these people and
uh so it's you know we've been doing
that for a couple years is there any
parallels between
the final completion that you feel with
programming which i think is a little
bit more definitive like there's
debugging the code doesn't work it's
messy and so on there's the early design
stages you're not sure
like how to have functions and classes
how it's all going to work and then it
comes together and it's really done
because it works and there's a cube
moving on the screen right right uh is
there any parallels between that and
music because are you really ever done
done
with a song
it's
it's exactly the same thing for me just
in that
it's art um i really believe that
we have not
fully encapsulated artists like when we
say art i think most people think
okay the medium must be
painting or drawing
or music
or writing
but i really believe anytime you're
creating some things
engineers
for instance you're creating something
with tools that you have and it can be
incredibly beautiful
and
so yeah i think
and it's never done
i feel like i look at songs that i've
done and i never felt
it you have to let
go or i have to let go and that's all
i'm just continually making myself let
go but i look at songs that i've done
and
wish
i had done more or kept going down that
road and what would have happened and
i'm really contained to because of what
our band is and and what our fans expect
and there's so much more to it that it's
like
i'm fitting in a box always
um you know it's like this song
shouldn't be longer than three minutes
and 30 seconds and
i don't know if i remember the chorus
after i heard it maybe i need to hear
the chorus three times instead of those
two times it's like there's there's
certain
especially in pop music it's really hard
to
um
yeah it's you there's con it feels like
there's confines even though people are
like well there's no confines but still
everybody's writing a pop song it's a
few minutes and are those explicit in
your mind or are they just kind of yeah
the gut is like you said chorus should
you have of course once twice or three
times is that a gut thing or is it a
rule thing you know i think it's a rule
i mean it's obviously a rule i impose on
myself nobody's
nobody's in my house saying hey dan if
you don't do this i'm gonna punish you
there's no major label president that's
like
imagine dragons needs to make pop music
dan you know what i mean my manager
doesn't even tell me that
i i do it because
it's what i perceive to be enjoyable i
grew up listening to a ton of pop music
and then i ended up being in what is
quote unquote a rock band which i've
never perceived it as that but
that's kind of what the world
has called it and that's fine but
um so you're a prisoner
of a prison that you yourself
constructed
there you go well i'm not confident
happy i guess what i'm trying to say is
i'm a happy prisoner of the prison that
i have created for myself and i made
that prison thinking that it was a
mansion
you